hey David do you watch Saturday Night
Live if so did you see Kanye West on SNL
put on a make America great again hat
and do an anti-democratic rant what do
you think of him
I never eat i'm i talk about Kanye West
I am stunned by how many people angrily
get in touch and say I'm unsubscribing
because you don't like Kanye West but I
have never liked Kanye West it's not
because I don't like rap it's not
because I don't like hip-hop and R&B I
go all the way back to you know 70s R&B
and rap and hip-hop and I have been a
fan of R&B artists dating back from the
70s 80s 90s 2000s and today something I
was like a radio DJ on one of those
stations I just can't stand Kanye West I
don't like his music I don't like him as
an individual based on his pomposity
delusions of grandeur and political
views quite frankly as of late and I did
see this video that Chris Rock who was
in the audience at this weekend this
past Saturday's SNL episode took of
Kanye West saying just dumb things about
Democrats and all sorts of different
stuff the audience booing like three
people were cheering I think that he is
the now let me be clear if he wants to
comment about politics I'm not one of
these people who says be an artist and
don't do politics or be an actor or or
do I'm kidding by the way when I say act
or or be just play basketball and don't
come anybody who wants to use their
platform to do politics I say I welcome
that there might be consequences to that
if people overall say you know what I
like how you play the game or I like how
you sing but I don't want to support
your views with my dollars and I'm gonna
make the decision not to do that that's
the free market that's actually the free
market of ideas and people can say I'm
not going to participate but I have
never said you should not use your
notoriety to do politics what I have
said is there are situations where
you're not just using your notoriety
you're actually using a platform that's
not a fair platform so let me give you
an example Al Michaels the football
broadcaster big Republican
back in I think it was oh for when John
Kerry was running for president he was
broadcasting a game in at Foxborough for
the New England Patriots and the
referees changed a call and he said well
the referee I'm paraphrasing the
referees have flip-flopped on the call
and we're certainly in the right state
for that that I found inappropriate
because you're in the midst of calling
the football game and you've been hired
to call the football game I'm fine
without Michaels doing politics
but do it on a platform or in a place
where it's actually maybe what you're
invited to do I did not think it was
appropriate to do this sort of like
uncontested turning a national football
broadcast into his political blog it can
be excused though because I'm sure it
was a spur-of-the-moment decision to
make that comment right okay thought
about that ahead of time whereas Kanye
West I thought hung out with a mag ahead
on yeah and I do wonder whether or not
this is something he genuinely believes
in like does he actually support Trump
is all avant-garde art so is it a
branding like you'd have to imagine he's
alienating a good portion of his fan
base here but then again he stays
relevant by being edgy and that's what
he did on SNL maybe and I don't even
want to read into the motivations what
he is saying is idiocy I don't like his
music
I think his political activism is really
dumb but you know what I'm not going to
his shows anyway so it's not he's not
really losing out by turning me off it's
a foregone conclusion by many people in
my generation that Kanye West is a
genius I've never seen that shown to me
now I mean I I've listened closely to
the things that he has to say I can't
even piece them together like they're
not even a cohesive thought I I know and
maybe that's because we're not smart
enough to understand him you have to
understand that that's a possibility pad
we just might not be able to interpret
ideas and language at the level which he
uses to communicate or something like
that